(engine revving)
- [Narrator] Little trees.
They're a rear view mirror staple,
protecting noses from offensive odors
all over the world.
But where do they come from?
Over 60 years ago, a scientist
by the name of Julius Samann
had a chance encounter with a milkman
that changed the course of the
air freshener game forever.
It was in Watertown, New York.
A milkman was making the rounds
when he stopped to speak to Julius,
a German Jewish chemist who fled the Nazis
and studied alpine tree aromas
in the forest of Canada.
Said milkman, began venting to Julius
about the stench that
spoiled milk left in his car
and thus the quest began
to destroy bad car odors.
Julius drew inspiration from
the tree aromas he studied
by infusing their oils onto paper.
In 1954, he filed a patent
for tree-shaped paper
infused with odor destroying air perfume.
Julius then started
producing the air freshers
out of an empty auto shop
and sending samples to local gas stations.
The little trees were a big hit,
and Julius successfully created the first
automotive air freshener.
Though the look remains the same,
the scents are forever changing.
Now the little tree
company has over 60 scents
and has sold over a billion
little trees worldwide.
(upbeat music)